[Music]
and now products is the only man
standing he's off at the site he's got
at Molly this could be perfect to stop
this defuse he tosses it out there
that's gonna slow things down tries to
find time skadoodle we'll get him and
the or have they got time they're just
gonna sit him buddy
CS go has many legendary names but some
legends have been forgotten he sees them
now they're straight headshot they have
no idea Smith's looking confused and
dazed but pronax is gonna play really
smart and sigh and probably just kind of
maneuver around the pillar until he
plants the bomb
all right in front of him snacks just
tries to put it down but he will be
dropped here eight seven in favor of
finna to get the end is attempted here
doe sure he gets the killer that's the
only thing that matters markeloff can
now just wait pro next tries to pick it
up he's gonna make it around the corner
and you will get a fun happy and he goes
down is so good allows for us to get by
walks out cold as ice and it's gonna be
11 to 4 products is a three-time major
champion something few pros can ever
hope to achieve but his name doesn't
mean what it once did but I all said to
ourselves if if I cannot compete to
become the best I don't let us stop
because I don't want my career the whole
thing I build up for for 17 years to
remember like a fool knocks pronax had
to choose between hoeing his dreams and
keeping his legacy from being destroyed
winning can't be the thing that drives
you always
in 2015 fnatic were on top of the world
guys please put your hands together for
your ESL one Katowice champions
they won two back-to-back csgo majors a
first in the history of the game but
Katowice and cologne weren't even their
first major winners a slightly different
lineup picked up fanatics first major
win two years earlier at Dreamhack
winter and JD all has to do is just wait
and buy time and there it is they win it
I look at the even card jumping up one
of the most composed people I think in
counter-strike
complete celebration but before that
major fnatic were struggling and they
were looking for an experienced a leader
who could show them the way in just two
weeks before Dreamhack they found their
man when I joined I think it was they
didn't really have an idea at all they
didn't have someone that actually put
time into thinking about different
strategies how to approach the game they
were just kind of mostly joining the
server playing pronax started playing
1.6 in 2007 so by the time he switched
over to csgo he had plenty of experience
and it wasn't long after his switch that
fnatic offered products a job as their
new igl and in one of his first
tournaments with the team pronax his
smart decisive leadership brought fnatic
their first major win the first major I
will never forget it like but I have
been playing CS for probably 10 years
without ever winning a big tournament so
it was definitely like yesterday who
huge mountain that just dropped off your
shoulders because you will like all of
us have been it was a dream come true to
be honest it's hard to describe how it
feels your your stare in the moment and
everything else disappears basically
pronax may have started his time on
fnatic with a bang but 2014 proved to be
a year of growing pains for the team and
fnatic playing it out really defensively
right now cajon falling down their
siblings with the kill is back to what
you want to but the position here from
Schneider it's not gonna be easy they
must know he's up here they spotted him
already
Schneider goes down and take a tough
they're gonna pick up the round for
Nancy
they could not make you work oh what an
upset
fanatic just wasn't performing up to par
so they went through a roster shaker
adding olofmeister and crimps and that
switch was the start of something
incredible
it's Dupree and AC buses fluttering
curbs fall around don't much time left
phonetic will get a Z flush against the
Fred Dupree know what up to the bob
diffuse has to happen and they're both
tagged up seized it does wrap around
through long but fanatic aren't playing
for long they are gonna look back in
time and now seize this part out
completely in the open but Zeus turns it
into a 1v1 flush alive on a slope trying
to hold as best he can Zeus jumps down
tries to find the ankle to flush I
instantly reacts playing for the bomb
just trying to burn as much time off of
this talk and Zeus will go down fnatic
take at 1614 to the 30th round of the
last map they take the title play all
the way and Navi Navi will have to set
up a second place yes l1 cut of ESA was
fanatics first a big triumph in 2015 and
he's back on it he's got the kid he's
holding it down I'm not sure there's
enough time fan out
ladies and children you're here soon
Tammany to champion top phonetic but
they didn't stop there B all he's still
this last line of defense essentially
because cribs takes out tans and pasta
with a flank on the Katniss could be a
huge moment for him if he can actually
get a kill defend this plan this would
be big JW takes out the long Mantha
pastas now giving away his position and
the plant his feet the fuse right now
nothing deposit could do they will be
able to pick up yet another title in the
year of 2015
fnatic with the dominant 300 win in the
finals they have to bring in fact the
bend is gonna go down the crowd is
chanting in the background you can hear
it they
the phone crowd
just up to flamey
2015 the next major ESL one cologne
turned out to be a historic tournament
for fnatic and pronax I was a bit of a
chance for a Cali shot there but he's
gonna be walking up the dog away his pro
nightspot secured Shima he can't touch
it ona takes in town what a quick peek
and that's gonna be fantastic winning a
very critical pistol round I don't think
that's any chance flusher looking to end
this it's gonna be a third major
championship and global Offensive are
indeed your ESL one cologne 2015
champions winning back-to-back yourself
as but of course more more than winning
back-to-back majors now three major
titles in their trophy case fanatics win
in Cologne marquee first time any csgo
team had ever won two majors in a row
and on top of that three major wins was
more than any other team had it took a
years for a team to beat fanatics record
bow off Meister JW flush Crim's and
pronax
they were csgo Swedish dream team and
pronax
was the masterful igl leading the best
team in the world famous in-game leader
he greets them up incredibly well of
course his pronax but nothing lasts
forever I had a problem with my briefs I
can practice as much and I think some of
the players they wanted me to pay more
but I couldn't then it was just
frustrating for everyone involved I
think he's had his moments and he's
shown that he can frag but if you're not
gonna be a hardcore fragging kind of
in-game leader you know in the in the
kind of fall in glaive vein you need to
bring something else to the table and
for pronax it was clever strategies and
knowing how to use his team but as the
game progressed csgo progressed it
became faster it became a bit more frag
heavy if you hit frag in this day and
age even as an in-game leader it's not
gonna cut it
the empire that pronax helped build was
crumbling around him envious now the
push comes around the back crimps he
might get shot the back
[Applause]
[Music]
they will take it out here to ETX
achieve beauty types for expansion you
your champion up all champions
it is envious you know still holding out
of that scope but he's playing on that
car position yep they've gotta go this
is gonna be a commitment be split again
passes there buddy smoke this time so
now it comes down to snacks who's
managed to pick up one they will at
least force TAS back in the site the
past is gonna come into this any second
and we'll above the smoke he takes down
two and it'll wrap it up virtus Pro are
going to the finals against TSM and
fnatic they'll bow out in third place of
the event the cluj-napoca major was the
last time pronax ever played with fnatic
exactly two years after joining fnatic
as their igl pronax is a journey with
the team was over but he wasn't kicked
for underperforming in fact he says he
left because he was bored of winning
first of all I actually thought about
leaving fnatic for a long time because
it's I mean when IO in fnatic I had won
gold we we wanted to be the best team in
the world and the we we managed to reach
that goal and after that it was like the
passion died within the team we didn't
have that much fun anymore when we
traveled it was more like okay not now
where we're going to destroy ment then
we go home and then we it was just I
just woke up everyday practicing doing
the same thing and it wasn't fun and so
I just wanted a new challenge for many
the obvious next step would have been
retirement pronax had already achieved
anything a csgo player could ever hope
to achieve and his legacy was secure
but products had other ideas I've always
done things my way and I always wanted
to create my own organization so I
didn't have the like I have done already
played for fnatic and in my eyes fnatic
was one of the biggest organizations in
the world or if not the biggest like
there's definitely I could have joined
face up times probably did obviously
this is just speculation but I think the
products was also trying to see into the
future in terms of right he's Hall where
the game was going he saw that he was
having more trouble sticking you know
keeping up and I think for pronax
god-sent was probably a play to try and
get into the business aspect of things
of the of the eSports side and to play
for the future right could see maybe
that the writing was on the wall in
terms of him being a player and so
perhaps he was trying to set himself up
for what's the next step in his career
and that could be potentially you know
becoming a member of the back office or
the front desk right instead of being a
player god-sent was pronax his baby
built by him from the ground up and he
was determined that he could climb back
up to the top with any roster I always
want to win it about that same time like
it wasn't I didn't create the team with
the mindset that we are gonna win
another major it's I definitely want to
do it but for me it was I tried to be
reasonable I wanted to create a team
that could be good that's also it's
marketed and marketable because for me
it was always about godson from that
point but running an org and playing at
the same time was a lot to handle
I was both focusing on the organization
and focusing on trying to come back as a
player I think I took too much on my
shoulders for myself considering where I
was in my life at the time pronax found
himself in unfamiliar territory and the
learning curve was steep pronax was an
experienced leader but he was just one
man honey saved to semi finals he's
being tanked up from Shaw picks off
through the woods
and get right will secure the
semi-finals than if they go through to
the finals to face off against Navi
ready for any sort of push from pronax
surely he's not gonna expect anybody to
be here nice easy kill one more kill
towards that sort of position where they
are going to be knocking good scent out
of the tournament two players remain JW
and Crim's making their way and it's all
going to be down to Cribs he's gotta try
crutches with the umps gonna find
himself a second looking for the third
but the bomb is now ticking away does of
himself a kitty off the plant should be
enough I think they know this is over
and that is it the thing that has they
have done it it's all that crow again
with this a k34 health left he's been
spotted and it gets fragged it's gonna
go the way of gambit and you can see how
much that comeback means to them Watson
had this game in the hands God sends
best placement during pronax his time
actively playing for the team was 9th
11th at the Ely major 2017 where North
sent them packing before the
quarterfinals
this is Finkle pro next flank he's been
quiet all game finds one elects to go
for a flash surely that gives me just
the killer that's all on Snyder to try
and force out double overtime or North
will rally back similar to what envious
did in the qualifier from 0 to 2 make
the playoffs and they've done it majest
and they are ecstatic after a string of
disappointing results pronax decided to
leave god-sent and try his luck
elsewhere the team decided basically
that they wanted to try it something
else and even like us I wasn't kind of
force anyone to play with me basically
and at the time like I was kind of fed
up with everything as well but pro Naxos
tins with digital chaos and ancient were
both short and disappointing one on one
with pal he's trying to hide saw that
foot he just gets him now POW has fallen
an arch has done it for K on the pistol
round 16 to 0
ancient out in YP the Columbus
yeah I mean that was that was a rough
one the lodge man years after his legacy
was destroyed by disappointing results
and forgettable teams pronax was finally
ready to retire pronax is retirement
match was kind of a bummer
ancient playing under the name god-sent
lost to gambit youngsters at copenhagen
games 2019 and just like that pronax
said goodbye to professional csgo for
good reaction to his retirement was
mixed some people paid tribute to as a
legendary past as one of the best IG LS
to ever do it others wondered why he
stuck around for so long without
retiring on top you want to give it the
last chance obviously if you cannot then
then at some point you can step down
yourself and saying well I can't do this
anymore I really can't improve myself
and all that kind of stuff so it's not
about stopping at the top that's more
like giving the last chance to be the
top if it doesn't work to stuff pronax
his days as a player were over but just
because he wasn't playing anymore
didn't mean he was leaving eSports
behind helping god-sent grow was what
helped pronax keep going long after his
glory days on fanatic so products knew
what he wanted continue helping his org
evolve so I continued playing basically
because I wanted to find a very good
team for God's earth and eventually I
knew that I was going to replace myself
regardless with someone that I thought
could surpass me basically as an idea
now this it didn't happen this way but
in my mind that was my plan basically
pronax returned to god-sent but this
time as a manager putting his leadership
skills to work behind the scenes
obviously some players you know as time
moves on yes you know it's time to hang
up the mouse but I don't know if I don't
think pronax overstayed his welcome per
se because when he goes down to God send
what's really expected of him right if
he's in a fanatic then if he's in a tier
one team holding that tier 1 team back
then yeah he's gonna get replaced or or
he needs to get replaced but if he's in
a god-sent he's probably forming the
next generation of tier 1 player at that
point
that can only benefit the csgo scene as
a whole products sacrificed his personal
legacy once he was a legendary igl with
three major wins but these days he's not
really remembered for that as much he
sacrificed it all to become part of
something greater than himself and no
matter what anyone thinks of him now
pronax has no regrets I could have
retired when I was on my high but for me
like I never seen my time is fanatic as
my legacy it's definitely a part of my
legacy but like I said for me it was
always about my next step which was
God's up and if I had to sacrifice a bit
of my own personal image to create God's
Son
I don't mind that at all like building
barbecue is down there I'm sure the mic
isn't picking it up but they're
literally building the barbecues in the
courtyard right now and they're just
like [ __ ] at all hours of the day
just drilling and sanding it's crazy
it's crazy I just said that in front of
a [ __ ] recording microphone I'm gonna
sound like a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
excited from the finished barbecues down
there I want to [ __ ] barbecue things